Now that we've talked a bit about how our variables x and y are related in this
equation we've developed for the total weight of the suitcase depending on the
number of glasses wiper sets that Grant puts in it, I think that the next step
to further understand the relationship here, is to graph our equation. Now, I
know that I've done some graphing for the class already on the tablet. But since
I really want to encourage you to graph on physical, actual graph paper, I'm
going to just show you a demo of how I do that. Justmake sure that you've got
the basics for setting up a graph and drawing a line totally down. So, I clearly
has to switch pens since this one doesn't write on actual paper. Materials that
are important for graphing include graphing paper, which is just paper with
lines on it, that create a grid. A ruler, like this lovely one right here. And a
pencil. I'm super picky about using pencils and not pens for graphing. I think
it's really important so that you can make sure that you can fix any mistakes
that you've made by erasing. The xy table we created earlier is going to be
really useful for helping us graph points. But before we can graph those points,
we need to set up our coordinate plane. So, we need to draw a set of axes, we
can plot these points on. So, start out by lining the ruler up with one of the
vertical lines on the sheet of paper. Over to the left-hand side, since all of
the values that we need to graph in this graph are both positive in x and y.
Sometimes, this won't be the case and you'll need to think about where to put
your axes, and how far to draw the x-axis in both directions and the y-axis in
both directions, so that you can fit all the important points on your graph. But
for now, I have drawn a y-axis. And now, I line up the ruler horizontally, you
can notice that it's positioned quite toward the bottom of the y-axis that I've
drawn, since I don't really need any negative y values for this. And once I've
got the ruler situated properly, in relation to this horizontal line r ight
here, I can draw my x-axis. Wonderful, so now I have a y-axis and an x-axis.
What's missing right now is some arrows. I know that the y-axis and the x-axis
both extend infinitely in both directions, they both go from negative infinity
to positive infinity. I also like to label the origin with a 0, and I label each
axis as well with a variable it corresponds to. Great, now I have some axis.
However, let's look at what numbers we actually need to plot. We need to plot
from 0 to 50 in x and from 7 to 32 in y. We've got 0 laid out, that's great. But
to go all the way to 50, I clearly can't have each one of these boxes stand for
1 on the x-axis or on the y-axis either. So, we need to make a scale. Since I
have quite a few boxes here, and I'm only graphing 6 points, I need to make
every grid length on the x-axis stand for 5. And just for simplicity, I'll label
every two grids with a 10. So, 10, 20, and so on, and so forth. I can do the
same thing or a similar thing for the y-axis. Here, I only need to go up to 32
though, so I can probably space my numbers out a little bit more. I've labeled
my y-axis that every 2 grid links stands for 5. And, of course, I've labeled it
all the way up. Now, that we have our axes set up, we can actually start
graphing points. This is sort of a tricky example to start with, so I'm sort of
glad that I picked it. Because you'll notice that since there are numbers that
end in 7 and in 2 on the y values, these aren't going to correspond exactly to
grid lengths here. So, this is a great chance to see that sometimes when you're
graphing, you don't have points that end up exactly where lines on the grid
cross. You have to just be very careful and estimate as closely as you possibly
can. To remind us of the coordinate or ordered pair notation that we'll often
see when we're moving to graphs, I've written all the data in the table here in
point notation. Okay, let's actually graph. First point, 0 7, so we start at 0
on the x-axis and move up 7 in y. The point halfway between 5 and 10 is 7 and a
half, so we're going to be right below that. And I'll put a point right there.
We have 10,12 so we go to 10 on the x, and 12, which will be just below this
line right here, which is 12 and a half. And we continue just like this. Hm,
something looks kind of funny to me. Let's check with a ruler to see if all of
these points lie on a single straight line. Clearly, this one doesn't, so I must
have done something wrong. It's really, really easy when you're graphing. Two,
when you move over on the x-axis and then up to your y-coordinate, accidentally
switch your hand position horizontally, and add to a graph in their own point.
This is why we just need to check our work very carefully. Okay. So, that was
the point 40 27,. So, I'll just graph that one again. 40, very carefully
following this line up to the 27 mark, that looks better than the other point.
So, you can see I must have just shifted my hand to right when I was graphing.
Okay. Now, that I have all my points, let's make a line through them. Rulers are
really helpful but you also have to make sure that you're using them as best you
can. I like to put the point of my pencil on a point and then line the ruler up
with the pencil tip, just make sure that the ruler's actually going to be in
line with the points. I can do the same thing with the last point I'm going to
graph. And now, I actually connect the points. Get a beautiful line. Wonderful.
Now, since conceivably, Grant could pack more than 50 pairs of glasses wipers in
his suitcase, I'm going to draw and arrow on the end of the line right here.
This indicates that the graph could continue increasing in the x-direction and,
in this case, the y-direction as well, past this last point that we graphed. I'm
not going to put one over on this end though because for the purposes of the
dealer we're dealing with, we're not going to have negative x values. Grant
can't pack a negative number of glasses wipers in his bag. This would be very
different though, if we were graphing other kind s of equations that don't
necessarily correspond to things that can't have negative quantities. So, with
most graphs, you'll see an arrow on the other end of the line as well. We'll see
that in later examples.